bonjour on a alors en fait vous êtes à
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle et
les employés semblent être déterminés
on ne va pas se laisser faire ce sont
les mots des employés de l'aéroport
charles de gaulle et orly qui sont en
grève depuis 11 heures exactement pour
de lancer est les baisses d'emploi les
plans à d'économie le rassemblement a
commencé ici devant le terminal 2 e et
le but est bien et d'aller jusqu'au
siège social il partira d'ici une petite
demi heure vous pouvez la voir sur les
images de lionel girard il y aura
plusieurs prises de paroles plusieurs
syndicats sont également présents dans
ce cortège vous voyez rapport s'ouvrir
hier cgt ou encore unsa certains
salariés sont toujours en chômage
partiel est difficile pour certains de
garder le moral une précarité qui a
augmenté il faut le dire en raison de
l'épidémie et des conditions de travail
qui sont de plus en plus dure on a pu
parler à quelques employés qui ont
témoigné à notre famille pour écouter on
demande un engagement de l'état dans
l'épreuve qui aujourd'hui concerne le
monde aéronautique
dans son engagement en restant
majoritaire dans le capital des paies en
soutenant
ce qu'on appelle l'hérault portes demain
puisqu'on a des enjeux environnementaux
on estime que notre boîte est une bonne
entreprise c'est bien pour ça qu'on y
tient et à la une histoire aussi qu'on
veut faire vivre et on pense que notre
entreprise a la capacité à la structure
pour pouvoir continuer à faire vivre et
à nous offrir des conditions de travail
raisonnables contrairement à tout ce qui
se passe sur la plateforme au niveau de
la sous traitance par exemple on a déjà
réussi à faire bouger les lignes sur
certains sujets on va continuer et puis
ben c'est le rapport de force qui
s'installe avec aujourd'hui on le voit
les salariés je pense qu'on va être
nombreux et c'est vrai ça va aussi faire
ça va permettre à la direction de voir
aussi que les salariés sont pas contents
plusieurs corps de métiers sont
représentés dans ce cortège 10 il est
aussi est les forces de l'ordre qui
encadrent le périmètre
quelques fourgons de police sont
présents ici aux abords de l'aéroport
d'autres rassemblements sont prévus dans
d'autres villes en france et notamment à
paris nissim initiative lancée par la
cgt fsu et solidaires
le secrétaire général de la cgt philippe
martinez appelé tous les salariés à se
défendre de son côté jean castex le
premier ministre a appelé au sens appelé
tout le monde à prendre ses
responsabilités
responsabilités notamment en cette
période d'épidémie en appelle à la
responsabilité notamment et des
cheminots puisque la sncf et la ratp
sont tendres elle également on a merci
pour toutes ces précisions